The People's Republic of China has
changed a lot since it was founded in
1949 as a hard line socialist country.
So much so that if Mao himself rose from
the grave,
it probably fall right back into it.
Yeah.
In the 1970s China was a country of
very,
very poor farmers.
Well,
now it's a world superpower and economic
powerhouse.
No country in history has grown so fast
or has gotten so many people out of
poverty as China has done in the last 40
years.
Okay.
Throughout this time,
this country has grown as an average
rate of almost 10% per year,
and most importantly almost 800 million
people,
more than the entire population of Latin
America,
Spain and Portugal have escaped poverty.
I'm pretty sure this isn't news to you
or anyone else.
Box.
How did China manage to change?
Do you think that this entire
transformation was the result of a
carefully drawn plan,
some intricate strategy maps out spite
China's leaders?
Well,
you viewer,
I think that this story has a twist that
is probably going to surprise you.
So listen up.
By the way,
before we get into the video today,
I did want to thank everyone who has
been supporting us on page on in just a
few days.
We've got 650 have you on board helping
us out in making these videos?
We're right now working hardware,
preparing a lot of surprises and we're
going to have great stuff in store for
people who are supporting us on paper.
You're on consider doing it if you want.
It would be cool.
There's a link in the description below
and let's crack on.
Okay.
Yeah.
On October the first 1949 miles a dong
proclaims the existence of the People's
Republic of China.
He did this from Tienanmen Square in
Beijing and he did so with a very clear
slogan and that was China has stood up.
Wow.
However,
in the following three decades that
reality had changed a lot.
Now is rather obsessed with the ideology
willing to implant the societal model
that he has.
In his mind,
that's pretty much any cost as among
other things to view where he thought
the Beijing could decide everything and
determine the future of everything.
Much
to produce,
what to produce,
how to distribute the workers,
how many factories were needed,
how the goods were to be distributed and
production,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
And not only that,
the other thing that was clear to mouth
was that any dissidents was a danger
that hat to be eliminated.
Of course,
as you can imagine,
these ideas in the hands of someone with
so much power and so much stubbornness
certainly had consequences.
Some studies estimate that during the
almost 30 years that mel was the supreme
leader of China.
Between 50 and 70 million people lost
their lives due to famine,
political persecution,
and absolute poverty.
Yeah.
And after 30 years in power,
after collectivizing all of China's
lands and properties and brutally
persecuting millions and millions of
intellectuals,
academics,
and anyone who wasn't comfortable with
the regime,
well,
China was plunged into misery,
cultural revolution,
wrecked,
devastation on the lives of millions of
Chinese people.
For 10 years,
the nation was reduced to a state of
barbarism,
Shao Hahn and associate professor at
China,
University of Political Science and law.
I've found time,
more than 80% of all Chinese people
lived in miserable conditions.
Famine was common.
Political terror purges where the order
of the day and the living standard swear
comparable to that of some countries in
sub Saharan Africa and all of this,
while Japan and the Asian dragons of
Hong Kong,
Taiwan,
South Korea and Singapore,
we're taking off enormously.
That's why we call and be surprised that
when mel died in 1976 the Chinese
communist party divided into three very
different sectors.
The radicals they'd by Jen Ching now's
own widow,
how gong fangs moderate reformers,
and it's the most aggressive reformers
led by Dang Shao Ping.
Yeah.
Leanne's after a lot of push and pull
and often making it clear that China
couldn't stay the way it was any longer.
In 1978 it was the latter.
The most convinced reformers who took
the lead.
Yeah,
black cat and the white cat.
Remember the questions that I asked at
the beginning of the video?
Well,
let's answer the first one right now.
How did China manage to change?
It's called
yes.
In December of 1978 at the 11th congress
of the Chinese Communist Party,
the reformist,
Dang she,
I'll ping,
took over the country's leadership.
Then Shannon Penn argued that the
ideological utopia that had damaged
China so much had to be set aside and
that they needed to commit to
modernization.
In fact,
you might already be familiar with his
most famous phrase.
It doesn't matter whether the cat is
black or white,
as long as it catches mice,
Dung shall pain,
and as a viewer,
that's precisely what he did for the
following 10 years because if we have to
say something,
it's that the reforms weren't exactly
very quick,
but you might now be wondering,
well,
okay,
Simon,
but what exactly were their priorities?
Well,
from an economic perspective,
we can classify the reforms into three
big blocks,
agriculture,
industry and trade and sweat.
It all began in the fields.
We've already mentioned that at the
time,
China was fundamentally a country of
peasants.
Well,
the agrarian reform do you collectivize
the countryside and the communes were
suppressed and replaced by the usual
family exploitation model.
In addition,
the so called household responsibility
system was implemented by which many
decisions Sanchez,
what type of crops to plant spot
investments to make what tools and get
and by past from the governments,
from the bureaucrats to the families
themselves.
And not only that,
the peasants had to sell parts of their
harvest to the state and then could sell
the rest on the free market,
a completely free prices.
And that was a huge revolution.
But this time the good kinds
agricultural production soared and food
prices dropped.
Well the peasants living conditions
improved a lot.
I'm,
the results were good.
So Beijing decided to apply similar
reforms to the industry sector.
That way the government gradually
transfer decision making from Beijing's
ministries to government owned
companies.
Yes,
the decisions where it's still coming
down from the government,
but let's just say they were working
under different criteria.
That one,
wait,
let's all buy less.
All throughout the 1980s governments
owned company managers were able to make
decisions such as sharing benefits among
workers,
paying productivity,
bonuses,
grounding the freedom to hire and fire
employees,
deciding which suppliers to work with
the setting free prices.
And the list goes on.
It makes sense because who better than
the companies own managers to decide
what they need to work better?
Well,
in addition,
this was all the companies by the
legalization of private companies.
So suddenly the government owned
companies,
they had competition,
and there was also a trade reform in
which little by little China allowed
foreign trade by largely dismantling
import barriers,
tariffs.
However,
we owns agriculture,
the reforms,
they did face a huge problem.
China was a very poor country,
and of course it has been either capital
nor technology.
So,
well,
what did the government do?
Well,
this gets interesting.
Okay.
Special economic zones.
Beginning of the 1980s China was a very
poor country.
It was close to the world,
and it lacks both money and technology.
Or what he did have was a large
workforce willing to work in better
conditions than the ones they had in the
countryside.
So under these circumstances,
then she,
our pings government decided for an
experiment.
They didn't want to completely renounced
the economic model of it.
They'd inherited from mouth,
but they did want to make something so
they made special economic zones in
areas where the communist system had
stopped.
Okay.
In these areas,
foreign companies could invest and set
up factories.
That is,
they had access to the Chinese
workforce.
That in itself was a huge advantage,
but that wasn't all.
They also have very few taxes,
relatively this will bureaucracy and
some no terrorists.
It was
essentially a smaller waist for
multinationals in the middle of the then
hostile and Hermetic People's Republic
of China.
Beijing's idea was very clear.
Bring technology,
bring capital,
bring work.
Initially for special economic zones
were set up.
Shen Zen Zhuhai shall men and Shanto.
These were so successful that the
authorities began planting them all over
the country.
Okay?
There's the case for example of
Shenzhen,
when the special economic zone was
created,
the area was nothing more than a poor
fishing village with just over 30,000
people.
Today it stands at 12 million
inhabitants.
It's GDP will soon as the past out of
Hong Kong itself,
and it's one of the world capitals of
technology and it's all happens in just
a few decades.
Do you know
the company is quite away Dji or 10
cents?
Well,
they're from this city,
these economic zones.
Success was so great that we can state
that they were the precursors of China's
opening.
The shenton special economic zone is an
experiment.
We need more time to see whether it has
gone well.
We wish it success.
If it fails,
it will provide some lessons.
Dung shopping because folks Dang shall
pings.
Initial idea was to use these areas,
not to open up the country to gain
resources so that the government could
maintain the old model.
It's often thought that China's
transformation was perfectly drawn
designs and calculated by the Beijing
government.
However,
and this might surprise you,
it wasn't like this,
the marginalist revolution,
Huh?
For the Chinese reforms where plans by
the Beijing governments,
but where are they really?
Well?
Well,
you see often Mao's death,
China with a wreck.
The last crusade of these so called
great helmsmen.
The Cultural Revolution had left the
country in tatters.
Mao's cultural revolution producer
results opposite to what he presumably
intended leading many Chinese solutions,
faith in their government altogether.
Frank Dakota,
Dutch historian who specializes in
modern China.
In fact,
it was during this period,
the black markets began to spread places
where people try to survive outside of
the system.
And that also meant a very important
cultural change.
Perhaps that's why often Mao's death
before the transitions chaos,
some changes began to happen
automatically.
For example,
while the government continued to
promote collectivized agriculture,
some regions revolted and decided to
implement this,
the family exploitation system on their
own,
even though this manager breaking the
law and returning de facto to a private
exploitation systems.
And of course,
as this initiative started gaining more
and more followers,
the Beijing government finally decided
to establish these changes,
uh,
state policies,
but it was actually following these
changes that caused the change in
society.
Something similar.
It happens with private businesses in
the cities you see often Mao's death.
Many young people had been sent to the
countryside,
returned to the cities,
and since there was no work,
they tried to sort it out themselves and
the government is simply had to accept
it and suddenly private stores be under
multiplied like mushrooms in every
Chinese city ending the state's
commercial monopoly once and for all.
And in a way,
the same thing happens with the
municipal and regional companies which
began to emerge outside of state
control.
This led them to be the most dynamic in
China for years.
Yes,
it's true.
Dang shopping's government didn't stop
these changes.
Is it?
On the contrary,
he ended up implementing them as
policies.
But as you can see,
a large part of the change,
far more than what we're often told,
came from the bottom up and not the top
down.
By the way,
maybe that's why China's transformation
was so great and it happens in such a
short amount of time,
by the way,
before you go and beat us up in the
comments,
we do know that Sean Penn was no saint,
he was a dictator.
And without going much further,
we can see that the tnm and repression
was his own
doing,
but now it's your turn.
Do you think China will ends up ever
becoming a democracy?
Well,
leave your answer in the comments below
as well as in this survey and I really
hope you enjoyed the video.
Please do hit like if you did,
and don't forget to subscribe to our
channel for brand new videos.
Also,
don't forget to check out our friends at
the reconsider media podcast.
He provided the vocals in this episode
that were not mine,
and as always,
thank you for watching.